I don't usually pork am I going to be
eating pork
this looks Asian oh this looks familiar
well I think it's me but these days I
feel like you can make anything look
like me I think this is called garb it
looks like some kind of appetizer lob it
smells good really fresh and kind of
like it has a sort of like tangy smell
to it's ground meat I mean it's kind of
a color of maybe like turkey or pork
right into it and I'm expecting Thai
this is gonna look gross spicy it's
sweet its tangy it's got peanuts in it
or just swallowed a pepper at the
beginning it was fine one right now and
the water wait is it fish okay it's a
little bit of spicy my lovin you're
gonna say I'm eating rat meat cuz it's
delicious I would guess pork or turkey
still but I know it can't be that cuz
that seems boring what that's so crazy
bold pig ears spin my ears are good they
must boil it like really really well
who's this tastes like very boiled Asian
people like using all parts of the
animal you waste none of it I imagine
ears tasting more like cartilage to be
honest I wouldn't have tried this if I
knew before what it was but now after I
tried it it's not bad doesn't taste like
rat